protecting consumers was definitely the
thing it turned into
maybe a bad idea slash good idea
i started making some prank listings and
then it turned into
how how scary could i make this and then
the wiretapping of the secret service
and the fbi thing happened
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford he literally wiretapped
the fbi and united states secret service
meet brian seeley senior security
architect and evangelist
cmtv technologies inc brian silly
welcome to my show how are you all the
way from seattle
okay thanks for having me yeah it's
always fun i know you're a cyber hacker
because it's 11 15 pm for you but it
looks as if it's
you know 8 or 9 a.m for you and so i see
already the
the mindset but brian you know that your
journey is
is so fun and i i'm already sad that we
only have 20 minutes to talk about it
because you've done some pretty
you know unbelievable things all the way
from being in the marine corps
in the signals intelligence all the way
to tapping the fbi and the secret
service
and not even getting caught telling them
that you're doing it in 2014
to be a pronounced sort of this hero
that now
and and now being a keynote speaker and
working on on working
with society to to think about how how
do we
work with the ever-changing technology
around us also from a cyber security
perspective
an author as well i probably missed 10
more things along the way but
what i'm really trying to gather here is
i have to understand why you do what you
do
and what did you feel doing what you did
and you know
where you are now with insights back
from all the way then so brian i talked
enough
take me back you know to 2002 you're in
the marine corps
what is that like what is it like being
in signals intelligence there
well i was uh i didn't quite make it
into the full signals intel unit i was
in the defense language institute um i
ended up getting separated medically
uh for a sleeping disorder which happens
i met a lot of really interesting people
some of um
what you would consider here is people
that track saddam hussein
um people that you speak languages to
then
do signals interception translation and
be able to provide real time
intel on the ground really really
interesting really smart people and all
we basically did was get into really
creative trouble
uh at the defense language institute so
it wasn't the typical
uh trouble that you'd get just fighting
in bars it was way more creative and
silly um fast forward
2014 uh i ended up getting clean and
sober
in 2013 uh getting divorced and then
finding myself with a lot of free time
and looking back and then looking at
where i'm at now
it the google maps thing was about
protecting consumers and people who
didn't know that they were being scammed
and that's been an overarching theme of
my career is like i i
tend to gravitate towards protecting
people from those who would take
advantage of them
whether it's us someone who got their
account hacked
um someone who thinks they're being
surveilled
i have several clients who've had
stalkers
and need help with privacy concerns
um so mainly i have a full-time job at a
company called
scientif technologies and we have
uh it's the some of the first technology
that i've been excited about since i was
like a kid
it it actually prevents zero-day attacks
because you don't need a signature to
know what these types of attacks are it
protects them in a dif from a different
perspective through a different lens and
i've never seen anything like it
um to give you context my boss directly
is the cso
of the company he has uh 35 years at the
nsa
so i know very very little about him
other than his name is gary
and he is my boss other than that like
you don't get much information out of
this guy
uh he's not a sharer but he's a really
nice guy he's really smart
why do you go into what i do worlds with
cyber security what
you mentioned as a kid you were excited
about some technology you're now excited
about this technology
where does is cyber security you know a
passion or is the passion protecting
people's rights
from those that are trying to infiltrate
those rights
yeah it's probably more of that i like
people as much as i do technology
that's why i end up doing public
speaking i enjoy it i don't get nervous
going up on stage whether it's
um i've always liked to talk i've always
been highly communicative
and if you can present something in a
fun way and be
engaging and be interesting you can hold
people's attention for a lot longer than
you than normal people would think
even for like an hour on a webinar i get
people going wow i
i didn't even notice that whole hour
went by because
it takes a little bit more effort but
not much
to be interested in your own subject
what you're talking about right
be a little bit more animated make some
jokes make people laugh
and it's hard for i think a lot of
people in cyber security
because there tends to be this polar
yes either you are really good at
technology and you're an engineer but
you don't like
people or people are really difficult to
understand so you focus all your efforts
into tech
and avoiding people or you're the
opposite and there's very few people who
kind of meet in the middle
right no completely okay so we're in
paint me a picture you're on this you
know you're on this trajectory to do
something that is
pretty unprecedented a little bit
dangerous you're not clear what the
outcomes are
oh yeah what's going on there brian what
is going on there
was i didn't feel that google or other
platforms were doing enough
to prevent what i thought was
a pretty universal problem in many
different countries in lots of different
industries but
you could go through the top 10 in
various categories and it was all
fake to give you context bing maps had
more
locksmiths in redmond washington than
there were actual
redmond there were actual locksmiths in
the entire state
so it was it was to the the order of
magnitude
at least two or three times hundreds of
locksmiths in one competing little city
all competing for your business which
really was just a few guys
but they found a way to overwhelm and
spam things so consumers are getting
uh all sorts of horror stories of like
they had their locks changed and they
went on vacation they came home their
house was empty
or they're being held up uh basically
extorted for money in the middle of the
night because
you call a locksmith at 2 a.m and they
show up and they're like all right you
need to give me a thousand dollars and
we'll drive you to the atm or we're not
letting you in your car
wow horror stories and it happens in a
lot of different industries but that one
was the worst so
protecting consumers was definitely the
thing it turned into
maybe a bad idea slash good idea
i started making some prank listings and
then it turned into
how how scary could i make this and then
the wiretapping of the secret service
and the fbi
thing happened and i love how your brush
i love how you're brushing through that
well i ended up having to i called them
i called the fbi to tell them
what happened because it all happened so
fast
i replaced the real locations on the map
with fake ones and then deleted the old
ones by flagging them as spam from a
number of ip addresses
so it looked like a bunch of consumers
were complaining they took away the spam
duplicate listing and left mine
which had a forwarding number that
forwarded all the calls to the real
switchboard
no one would know the difference right
and i could record calls and it worked
really well really fast and i
panicked really really hard because at
that point you're like i'm gonna go to
jail forever
so i called some friends i called the
fbi the next morning they hung up on me
after a few minutes
and then i walked into the secret
service office to tell them and it was
basically like a magic trick because you
have to convince them and they weren't
convinced they told me to leave
so i have the guy on the uh there's
three agents sitting in this room
we're all looking at each other like i
can convince you if
in five minutes i can't i'll leave
call the secret service in dc right now
and he pulls his phone out
and he taps on it and this would only
work if he was using google maps
to find what he was looking for i was
betting
that he would search for secret service
washington dc
or washington dc secret service because
that
search query would give you the result
that was mine
and not the real one if he had used
apple maps it wouldn't have worked
yelp white pages but we all trust google
that was another part of the message
we trust what google gives us even the
secret service even the government
so he did it he talked to the guy on the
phone he
knows the guy professionally they've
already spoken before
he hangs up the phone and i get a
notification push play
push speaker and they listened we all
got to listen now the other two agents
weren't on the phone call
we all got to hear the other guy's voice
and the first thing out of a
the main guy's mouth was oh
and then they took all my stuff and they
handed me a form that said
these are your miranda rights you're not
being arrested you're not being detained
but we'd like you to come back to talk
with us
for four hours and we're going to ask
you the same questions over
and over and over and over just to make
sure your story doesn't change
unexpected a little bit unexpected and
i'm sure that the consequence of them
praising you and versus you know um
giving you some sort of ramification or
punishment that's even more surprising
but what is that like sitting there and
you're saying you know
you i know i did something okay i'm
dealing with a group that
nobody really knows what this is about i
have no idea how this is going to end up
like what what is going through your
mind in that moment
every choice i'd ever made up and led me
to that point
was like huh was this a big mistake
right like do i wanna is this the hill
that i wanna die on like do i really
wanna go down
like proving a point i mean i'll be
right but i'll be in jail like that
doesn't sound fun
i you know so it i didn't know what it
was gonna go like um
it didn't seem that i was gonna go to
jail right away and then they told me
they're like well we obviously know that
you don't have any criminal intent you
came to tell us
part of prosecuting someone is criminal
intent
and since i told them first i didn't try
to profit off it
it was uh better received um having a
top secret clearance in the marine corps
probably helped
and so i think i got lucky on a few
different fronts
um
they were able to tell google to shut
things down how does
how does this play into the greater
picture motivation that you have
regarding
this idea of protecting privacy and
protecting the protecting citizens from
the ever-changing technology because
that is something that you've written
about you've talked about
where are you at with that now
it definitely lets you know that the
biggest companies can still make
mistakes
and people can groups of people can
still be wrong
and you can still it doesn't mean your
opinion is
necessarily wrong or because of how many
people you have on your side
you can definitely and should
uh make your voice heard and take the
steps and sometimes it's going to take a
lot of effort to get people in
i'm not saying wiretap any federal
agencies i'm definitely not encouraging
that because they are not happy
with with you when you do that they
frown on it
severely but make your
take things and keep taking them until
they can go no further sometimes that
means going to the media
oftentimes people will find a bug in a
piece of software
and a developer won't fix it and if you
deem it's important enough
it's hurting people your obligation you
give them like 30 days
and whatever there's lots of blogs about
this but how many days do you give them
before they fix it before you disclose
this to the media
to let them publicly apply pressure
right i think that's a valid tool
because it's an accountability piece
right and so what what what is your
belief about
but you know the world that is changing
very quickly so
you know i spent quite a few years in in
this space myself thinking about you
know
the different canon mouse game that that
is you know just
natural for for anything that is
anything like it the ever-changing
technology that we see
versus you know the average consumer the
average citizen that doesn't isn't
really aware
you know of of what's happening right in
front of our eyes i'm not even aware of
most of what's happening on my phone on
my computer i just accept it as it is
where are we headed and and where do you
see yourself
say empty or in general you know
advocates for this type of stuff
in the world what what is this sort of
like this this give and take that we
have
uh that most companies don't provide
uh so you know what a service level
agreement is
but please explain our company a service
level agreement is basically like a
written contract that says we perform so
we guarantee
99.9 uptime of our server or our
service so that if we fall out of that
service uptime guarantee
we can we have to pay you back money
that you've spent on the service or
whatever
we provide an sla with a guarantee
against hacks and i believe we're the
only company that offers that
with the sort of strict non-general
language
so protection against zero days with an
actual contractual guarantee so that you
don't pay
if you're exposed and or hacked
and in a way that i i would offer a
reward or talk to the ceo and be like
you should do a challenge to where if
you can actually change something or
break in you should get a really really
huge award
make a big challenge out of it i think
he's still entertaining the ideas we've
been buying up other startups and
growing in size and um
been pitching some very serious players
and it's really interesting technology
the way he approached it he doesn't have
kids
and he's been really successful in his
career and i think he spends a lot of
time
focused on one passion and that was this
wow so the results kind of speak for
themselves
do you think that the concern that you
had in 2014
realizing you know what's happening and
realizing the discrepancies and taking
action
are these things that you know the
average person should be concerned with
them
or these things that you know large
bodies
that are dedicated to protecting civil
rights to be concerned because i think
that's an important
question in regards to you know how
should society
look should there be these you know
freedom fighters that are experts and
they're the ones dealing with this and i
as an average citizen should just step
back and accept the world as it is
or should each person be proactive in in
taking you know
really critical thinking about what is
happening with our own data with our own
life
and where are we being you know
infiltrated or penetrated you know
through technology
i think if if you live in the world you
have a certain responsibility
maybe to yourself to protect yourself
from
uh fire or bees
or getting if you're going to step into
the street you should know that cars
they hurt when they hit you you know you
can't stop all the cars from existing so
you got to watch out and cross the road
at the appropriate time
if you use email not everyone is the
nigerian prince who wants to send you
money no one if you're using email you
need to be aware of the dangers
you're like oh no it it just
you have to be aware of of the risks and
the dangers of whatever it is you're
playing in
if you go into the jungle maybe worry
about quicksand or
snakes or bears or whatever it is that
you where you're
at you don't have to worry about polar
bears in the middle of the desert
that's not a problem but you have to
worry about scorpions and snakes and
whatever
sand heat prepare for whatever
environment you're in
therefore if you're using the internet
you need to be an educated consumer
and understand the scams and risks
associated with it while other people
are trying to eliminate the ability of
them to create
more hazards and more dangers it's not
everyone's ability to do that
so you need to be at least aware of what
what's going to be risky behavior
so now let's play a game and go you know
10 years
to the future the world keeps on
changing
at a faster and faster rate every day
that goes by
we have companies like scientific we
don't have a lot of them unfortunately
because
you know it is sexier to do other things
sometimes than to
fight for consumer rights and and and
find those zero-day attacks
i never got into this because i thought
it was sexy
the average consumer unfortunately lacks
an understanding
of the technology around us because it's
just changing every day and
people don't generally read the fine
print of everything
are you optimistic about you know where
we're headed are you
not so much like what should we be
expecting
oh it could go either way uh i hope it
goes in the way that
results in more simple sophisticated
uh mature technology and usage for
people to where people can't get hacked
as often uh
people can always scam other people with
an email you send one person an email
doesn't mean you're a spammer
and you get them to invest in your ponzi
scheme
it wasn't a detectable scam until it was
identified as a scam later and you
bought boats and didn't invest the money
um people always be crappy they'll
always be really shitty people
however uh breaking in through the
technology stack
um i think there will be more and more
mature solutions out there developed by
bigger and bigger companies that
realize okay we can't put out a product
every five minutes
that's gonna be bulletproof we have to
spend longer on this
we have to test it more if you have a
car you can't just
when you've built cars in the first
years of automobiles
you could put anything on the road it
was fine even if it killed everybody
no one cared there were no laws then
they had seat belts
and then you could like oh there's
regulations the reason that cars look
the way they do today
is because they have to have headlights
they have to have tail lights they have
to have rear view mirrors
they have to have certain things that
shape the car in us within a confine
right
the same way that your clothing is
designed and your house is designed to
prevent one thing
what breaking in
sorry it's fire everything everything
all the building materials
even your kids pajamas are fitting
so they can so they avoid being caught
on fire if they get near an open flame
because the last thing maybe you don't
want your kid running around on fire
it's definitely not on my to-do list wow
i well i definitely learned something
new here i have one more question to
you to wrap your head around that is the
idea of deep fakes i've been looking
into this
for quite some time now and something
that i'm
deeply deeply scared of and
particularly as i'm as i'm looking at
both
the side of the people that are trying
to detect deep fakes and the companies
that are leveraging
you know everyday new models to create
them at an unprecedented speed
what i'm most worried about is that
people don't really talk about it
it's not really in the mainstream of
things even though it's happening
so what is your take sort of on on you
know consumer privacy
and civil rights when when we're talking
about something where
reality is being distorted
oh that's going to be a good thing um
you're going to have to see
someone come up with a multi-cam
authentication method set up to where
you have multiple cameras from different
angles that all have to be
authenticated and then checked and so
that they're running the exact same
software and that hasn't been tampered
with
therefore all the different angles match
up with all the lighting
so it's measuring all these things so
you can detect a deep fake
with photography because no one's going
to be doing three-dimensional deep fakes
for a while like it's there's going to
be ways to stay ahead of them which
just puts technology uh
in that sort of hot seat of developing
something to challenge it because yes
you can put someone's
i've seen the way it all gets done and
it's really sophisticated and you get
some really good stuff going
all of a sudden you've got an app that
can stream
three seconds behind and it's just
putting chris farley's face on your face
talking with his voice that's a problem
i
although i would like to see movies
re-tooled with different actors that i
like
or like what happens when kevin spacey
gets caught now he's off netflix could
you just re-edit all his movies and tv
shows to take him out of it
unbelievable that's kind of an
interesting concept
actors right now never die right and i
think that really they you know
the scariest part that i've observed is
the democratization of those tools and
i've been reading some
some nice you know medium articles about
how to set up your own deep fake
you know you know deep fake model on
your computer
as a computer scientist you don't even
and it's like literally you know 20
lines of code with the pre-trained model
and and it's scary it's scary to me that
you know it's so democratized and every
programmer
can pretty much you know set set it up
and create whatever application they
want with deep fake
as a part of it and and i'm mainly
hopeful and excited about you know the
other the side of companies like sampdev
that that are taking the you know the
the other side of trying to defend
against that
and but brian i really want to thank you
for coming on the show i truly
appreciate it i know how busy you are
and i can't believe it's so late for you
so thank you for doing this
and i have one last one hopefully you'll
have me on
when uh i finish my book this year and
maybe like six months
a hundred percent do we we can already
set a date for that and i need three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
tall funny kind
i love it brian thank you very very much
stay safe stay healthy keep protecting
us and i'll see you in six months
six months for the launch of the book
sounds good
thanks for having me